when did you start modeling how did that
come about I needed more money at Uni
the same reason that I started Club
promo and also I think because I was so
unpopular and on the outside looking in
as a kid I wanted to do things that made
people need me or want me say I'm
popular why I'm popular I just didn't
connect with other kids I was bullied
not insanely badly but I was pretty
close to the bottom of the hierarchy
there so I think that as I grew up the
belief that I needed to do things to
make people want me or need me came
through so being a club promoter if I'm
the guy that's got all the bands to VIP
you need me that's obviously not a
particularly healthy way to view
yourself or the world I think looking at
that I had tried to find a way to make
people need me and if they needed me it
didn't matter if they didn't like me
with modeling as well well people that
are models are high status they're seen
as someone that is held in good esteem
and maybe people want to be around a
model so don't get me wrong that wasn't
the only reason I did it paid well and
it was fun and I did DJing and I did
reality TV and it was just a Litany of
things a professional party boy would do
and then yeah it got toward the end of
my 20s and thought is this really all
that I've got to offer and that was when
the podcast started